they have everything and nothing the
rainforest of DRC provide for the tens
of thousands of small communities who
live there from a roof over their heads
to food for the pot
but infrastructure is minimal schools
and hospitals if any are barely equipped
electricity none the question perhaps
oil can change things for the better to
find out our next mode of transport
the nearest Village let's go
there are no roads this is the only
sometimes precarious way to go the path
is hazardous
we eventually arrive pretty much the
whole village come to hear our
conversation with the chief
and he's defiant
my first reaction is that people would
have to kill me and then kill our people
before this happens our everyday life
depends on the river if anything happens
to this River our life's destroyed
outside a village Elder sings the
ancient song of the river show me the
way to land
[Music]
the next day we head off to a
neighboring blog that's up for auction
here we were not welcome you know you
get a very real sense of the depth of
feeling here just by driving along the
track through these little communities
being mistaken to being part of the oil
exploration project and quite a lot of
people the adults have come running out
shouting get out of here we don't want
you here we want to keep our forest
leave our forest alone and it's it has
got quite aggressive as well
villagers berating our producer Alan
yakani as we tried to explain we're just
wanting their opinion
we move on eventually able to make our
intentions plain the message is clear
I'm not happy it's the first time we've
heard of it I cannot be happy with the
new nude we'd have to give up our
village where we have links to our
ancestors we cannot accept this
the focus should be on Community
Development not oil the government
should bring support for agriculture we
need seeds so we can grow things
tomatoes for example not just one or two
crops
people are very well aware of the wealth
potential of their country but as
they've seen with a huge mining profits
generated in the east of DRC nothing
ever filters down to the poor
the visceral connection to the land and
a total lack of faith in the government
means for these communities at least oil
exploration is a non-starter
Nick Clark Al Jazeera isoko Democratic
Republic of Congo